um hello testing testing 1 2 3 we have a
new Macbook in the house also a new mic
because mine is still packed and I
didn't feel like unpacking my gear I
just got back from traveling and as I
got home UPS arrived at the same time it
was such a beautiful moment with my new
space black fully specked out M3 Max
MacBook Pro so let's open this up check
it out I know I already did an initial
review but I wanted to just show you
guys the 14in in comparison to the 16in
and oh I'm just so excited because this
is my personal device and I can finally
set it up edit and get
going oh you beautiful beautiful machine
you are so sweet I can't wait this space
black is so beautiful and I'm so excited
for this new look did I hit record up
there she
did oh I'm so excited like it's exciting
opening up the review units but when
it's my very very own so much more
exciting here it is
beautiful little
MacBook check it out oh yeah it's so
light it's so powerful I cannot wait to
plug everything that I possibly can into
this until it yells at me and says sorry
you have maxed it out got our charger
matching mag safe now let's open it
[Music]
up so beautiful man the space black this
is just it's like a whole vibe
so I have another little something to
unbox I unfortunately left my fanny pack
in a car in New York when I was there
for the Apple events and my new USBC
airpods were in there and I'm so sad so
I ordered another pair but I'm hoping to
get them back because the guy said he's
going to return it to a hotel today that
my sister happens to be staying at in
New York it's a fingers crossed that he
actually does cuz I did pay money up
front before he dropped the bag so I'm
hoping that he follows through on his
promise but just in case airpods are
life so I ordered a new pair
these ones I got engraved I actually
forget what I engraved I think I did a
pig we're going to find
out can you guys imagine how sick matte
black airpods would be think about it
English as the main language press the
return key I wasn't ready for you I'm
doing something else right
now oh it is it's a little pig emoji oh
my God it's so cute look at
it yeah super cute ooh new USBC cable we
love that I forgot that that comes with
it so thoughtful swap out those ear tips
for the extra small it's still so wild
to me that I have not been able to use
any airpods until they made this extra
small ear tips like finally they work in
my ears it's truly a magical experience
now that'd be really funny if I ordered
the wrong ones and I didn't order USBC
but I second Jen I hope you're us you
are uspc oh gosh I ordered them in such
a panic I didn't pay attention I am a
liability shining shimmering absolutely
Splendid oops she has stepped on
something she's back we've got our space
gray previous Mac and we've got our
brand new 16in M3 look at this family
you need a little light on you there it
really is pretty wild how light this is
compared to the space gray although in
this light it looks this looks exactly
the same because this light is very very
bright but when we take this to the top
down you'll see the difference this poor
MacBook like it's not even a year old
and it has been through so much so yeah
here they are next to each other and
then we've got the big boy like look at
that you're having trouble focusing I've
noticed what's your what is your problem
manual focus you're in the 16 so you can
see the size difference I mean that's
that's a significant chunk like that's
like a a small Olive Garden bread stick
right there and and that and Olive
Garden bread sticks are pretty decent
size but I would say that that's about a
bread stick size size difference that is
a scientific measure measurement if I've
ever heard one so this is kind of just a
short little video unboxing and showing
you kind of the size differences between
the 14 and the 16 and the color
difference with the space gray let me
see what else I have do I have anything
else for
you I thought this was silver but this
is also a space gray MacBook this is the
blue and we've also got the gold I need
a
silver I returned with another Mac this
is super old this one's so old that this
still has the light up logo but that's
kind of like a little silver reference
we' got a lot of stuff going on here um
and it's also very hard to see in this
lighting so you can see if I lift this
up you can see the blue
color and this gold looks very silver to
me so if I hold this over here in this
realm I this is the Starlight actually
gang's all here I'd love to hear from
you guys though what is your favorite
color that the MacBooks come in I'm a
huge fan of the space gray so I'm very
excited that this has now joined the
family although now I've got like all
this titanium I just got the titanium AA
ring we got the titanium Apple watch and
they do look really nice together though
so that's great well thank you guys for
watching if you want to watch some more
videos I'll put them here on the end
screen and of course if you want to
check out my M3 review with the iMac and
the new space gray MacBook I will put
that here at the end as well and if
there's anything that You' like to see
me test out in a future video because I
will be doing a followup doing some more
testing and of course once I get all of
my apps and projects on here it'll be
really fun to see how fast this really
is in comparison to my previous M2 Mac
book I'll see you guys in the next video
bye oh you're okay you're like stuck
solid who are you I'm confused nothing I
just don't even know
anymore what have I got myself into